I love the show so much fun to make
because every deal is different and
after all you only need one good idea it
changes your life forever welcome to
another episode of ask mr. wonderful and
I mean ask me anything you ask the
questions and I give you the answers
bring them on
hi mr. wonderful my name is Paul I
wanted to be an entrepreneur my entire
life and yet here I find myself at the
age of 38 working a nine-to-five job and
never having taken the plunge and
started my own company I'm married I
have two wonderful kids I'm the primary
breadwinner for my family we've got a
mortgage to pay health insurance is due
my company it now seems like it's too
late
it seems selfish and an unnecessary risk
to put the livelihood that my family has
come to depend on at risk in order to
chase my dream do you think that I
should give it up or do you think I
should continue and if so how how do I
justify taking that chance and risking
what we have for something that might
not work out thank you
Paul it's a really really interesting
question and when I get all the time and
basically in your situation no just
kidding let me tell you what I really
think you should not risk your family's
well-being what you should do is work at
night and on weekends on something
you're passionate about to find out
whether or not it's going to work before
you take the leap if you can actually
prove what product or service has demand
and people start buying it from you you
can do it like everybody else does it's
a side hustle until it has enough
critical mass for you to jump ship that
way you don't take a huge risk I would
not risk my family's income but if you
know something that you really like you
can pursue it at nights and on weekends
yeah it becomes tough to go to soccer
games and picnics but that's okay
because you're pursuing that dream at 38
you're not that old you can definitely
take a risk but you're not going to give
up your primary income until you have
enough
proof of concept proof of customer proof
of sales proof of cash flow and all
those things can be done over a couple
year period of doing it as a side hustle
that's how entrepreneurs in your
situation get started good luck my
friend
hello mr. wonderful my name is Greg
Smith
I live in rosebud Alberta my question to
you is is we've recently purchased a
cafe and it seems to be blame quite well
although we would like to bring more
people to our town so what I have
started to do is I built a market so we
have 60 vendors that come on Saturdays
and then I've also created a ghost walk
where and people get to walk through the
town and we have a very talented man
that sort of shows them around the town
and of course then they get to see a
ghost and we're trying to find other
ways we can bring more people to this
small town what ideas would you have
that would really grab people rosebud
Alberta is very famous for its theatres
and clays hey Craig in rosebud Alberta
you know you have to tell a story if you
want more people to come to rosebud you
have to tell them why it's an
interesting Drive why it's an
interesting day and why lunch or dinner
at your cafe is the peak of the whole
thing
I mean there must be some attributes of
that town that are interesting that
people should see but anything like this
has everything to do with social media
and building up a base of followers that
you become sort of the highlight of
explaining to people let's make a day in
rosebud something romantic for you and
your significant other this happens all
the time successfully using Facebook
Instagram even Twitter anything on
social media that compels people to see
something that they want to actually
experience in person really matters and
you don't do it out of town or special
do something about coming to the cafe
meeting you talking about rosebud giving
them a Blue Ribbon award for showing up
there be one of the few people on earth
that have actually seen rosebud and
signed the book get a big registry get
them to sign it and then post the
registry and celebrate those people
thanks for coming to rosebud you'll be
remembered forever here's a picture of
the guy that showed up
you know there's a place in Amarillo
Texas called the Big Texan where they
serve a steak its 87 ounces and you can
eat the whole thing by yourself within
an hour it's free yeah that's pretty
brutal and they have pictures of
everybody that's gone to Amarillo Texas
to do it
same kind of idea my friend you make it
a destination you put a book up you post
the pictures and people want to be part
of that community the Rosebud memorial
book there you have no extra charge of
this advice mr. wonderful thank you hey
Cooper great question I've been
investing in line my whole life my whole
investing life anyways and drinking it
too I might add the best way the most
liquid way the most strategic way to
invest in one is to buy French Bordeaux
futures this is where you buy a case of
a fine French wine long before it ships
so that you have almost an option to
purchase the case generally done about
eighteen months before the wine is made
available sometimes twelve months you
could find all of this stuff online and
then the idea is that you take delivery
of it but if you're going to take
delivery of a case of wine you have to
have a place to store it and that's
where wine collecting becomes important
you have to build a cellar keep it at 58
degrees at the right humidity and I have
five sellers around the world I invest
in a lot of wine futures but it's not
very liquid business in other words it's
expensive to resell wine using an
auctioneers involved for 15% but I have
to admit over time I have made money
buying French Bordeaux's and burgandy's
sometimes extraordinary returns but most
of the stuff I buy I want to enjoy with
my family or friends or whatever so it's
not the greatest thing to invest in as a
pure investment because you end up
drinking it that's the problem
hi mr. wonderful how are you thank you
very much for this opportunity mr.
wonderful hits a problem I just received
an order from a major store and I don't
have the working capital to finance it
I don't have the cash or inventory to
fully afford it but I do have a good
amount in receivables which I expect to
get after 60 days six zero two things
that I try to solve this is the first
one is that to get a loan from regional
banks and friends but I didn't have much
luck the second is the I find I found
some of the summary receivables but they
weren't a huge huge huge discount if I
sell to them then I would make zero
profit for my receivables since my
margins are on right below I'm in the
manufacturing business two solutions
from my point of view is to tell the
store that I could only afford to
fulfill less than one third of the order
but I'm afraid that I may lose them the
other is the celebrity so mr. wonderful
which one do you think is the best
option and thank you very much for your
time Robert your situation is both good
and bad first of all you have demand
which is always good the fact that you
can't fulfill it is bad
factoring receivables is a delicate
business factoring rates are now between
9 and 17 percent you're probably
experiencing that maybe the compromise
situation is to fulfill some portion of
this and ask the vendor to pay you maybe
30% up front to help you I mean very
often being honest with your customer
explaining the dilemma you're in and how
much you want to help them is the best
way to do it instead of using a factor
that's gonna cost you 17% go to the
customer say look if you could front me
30 or 40 percent of this order I'll
fulfill all of it because I want to
service you I wanted to everything
power I'd start there factoring is very
expensive all of my shark tank companies
go through this dilemma all the time
factoring is expensive there's no
question it's generally all of your
profit to get cash flow to keep the
business moving and scale it up and be
more productive but the customer can be
your first line of defense and they may
want to help you the way I've just
suggested ask for thirty to fifty
percent upfront on that order if they
trust you they may consider it thank you
[Music]